America's about the pursuit and so I
think that trashing ourselves I think we
are actually hey guys I'm off the grid
for August but here's a generic intro to
a clip we wanted to show you
the the the country has never fulfilled
his promises of Freedom liberty and
justice for all it's always been Freedom
living the Injustice for some usually
that sum is uh white people so here's
what I would say in response to that
that is obviously true that the nation
has fallen short of our promise since
our founding
but walk through some obvious facts
about America
we're not founded on an ethnicity or a
monarch or a food or even a religion
were founded on a set of ideals that
brought a group of people together in
1776 and we live by those ideals at
least we aspire to those ideals today
a nation that aspires to ideals that's
not made up of gods but made up of human
beings will always fall short of those
ideals
our worst hypocrisies as a country and
we have many of them
our worst hypocrisies
are our best evidence that we have
ideals at all you take a look at other
countries nobody ever calls the Chinese
Communist Party a hypocrite or China
hypocrite or Iran a hypocrite why is
that because to be a hypocrite you at
least had to have ideals in the first
place and so we're imperfect but we are
about the pursuit of a more perfect
union The Pursuit of Happiness America
is about the pursuit and so I I think
that trashing ourselves I think we are
actually because you know we never were
included in those ideals originally
originally yeah but never enough
originally are two different things
originally that's true over 250 years of
progress if you had somebody who was in
1870 looking at the world we live in
today if you had somebody in 1960 who
was looking at the world we live in
today as it relates to race in America
we would be darn close to what they
would have thought of as the promised
land so I think we have to recognize
that America is about that Pursuit
we're a lot further along than we were
250 years ago we and here's the other
thing too we got to set our expectations
we will always fall short of our ideals
by definition if there are human beings
and not Gods living in a nation that
aspires to ideals we are Fallen man is
Fallen that's what makes us who we are
but what also makes us different from
animals is that we have ideals so
America's founded on our Humanity that
we can believe and aspire to something
that we will still fall short of that's
what makes this country beautiful and
that's why
that's why I'm in this you ask me why am
I in this I care about Reviving pride in
that Nation because if we get in the
habit of just bashing that country what
are we bashing we're bashing the last
best hope that man has for aspiring to
those ideals tell me who else has done
better I'll wait